t-mobile was very popular in the early
2000s but smartphones became popular
t-mobile fell into an abyss losing
several billion dollars per year in 2012
and 2013
despite this tea will was somehow been
able to compete against rising than AT&T
and go to be a strong player once again
so why the t-mobile fail in the first
place and how were they able to manage a
strong comeback make sure stick around
till the end of this video to find out
[Music]
welcome to hari sadhus so the history of
chemo was actually very short as it was
established very recently in 1994 they
were originally called moisturing
wireless PCs and they're a subsidy of
Western Wireless corporation they
provide on digital wireless personal
communication services to 19 FCC defined
metropolitan areas this was perfect for
Western Wireless has allowed them to
expand into urban service and this
greatly complemented their analog rural
service cellular one on June 1st 2001
Dutch telecom acquired moisturing
Wireless for thirty-five billion dollars
and by the end of 2001
yeah 19,000 employees serving over 7
million customers soon they changed her
name to t-mobile USA Inc and start
expanding rapidly into California and
Nevada t-mobile was flip phones and
their prepaid services were so popular
that anyone who lived here in time
period probably knows the teabolo jingle
they continued to go and in 2007 they
acquired soncome wireless Holdings for
2.4 billion dollars decided 1.1 million
more customers and expanded service
across the US but right after this smart
for slate took off and no one wanted
TiVo host flip phones and nobody wanted
her terrible 2g only network for their
smartphones either this demolished email
in just a couple of years and Dutch
Telecom was looking at cell team up with
someone else
in 2011 a TD offered 39 billion dollars
to acquire t-mobile this would have been
great for AT&T as it would push their
user count to one
thirty million subscribers making them
the largest wireless network in America
but the US Department of Justice blocked
the acquisition and this meant trouble
for t-mobile their stock price had
plummeted
they're losing Mayan left and right and
the future seemed pretty bleak for
t-mobile but t-mobile fate would
completely change as John ledger was
appointed CEO in September of 2012 she
had a vast experience working on an
executive at AT&T for almost 20 years
and also working at Dell for sellers
before that and just one month after he
comes in they merged with metro pcs yes
this gave t-mobile much more financial
resources which allowed them to expand
their LTE networks John ledger was all
about the on carrier approach this was
his policy or buy your business will
give you a stupidly good deal I'll make
sure that it's a saved edition urban
legends say that an employee once told
ledger that their network sucks and he
replied you're framing the question
wrong it should be at what price is our
network not suck and then price it at
that level and that's exactly what they
did there are no contracts low prices
global coverage global free roaming
tethering and of course unlimited data
had never before seen prices every time
they assassin that customers hated they
fixed it and they relentlessly added
stuff that customers wanted they still
had bad service especially compared to
their competitors but there's a huge
demographic that's ok with mediocre
service probably low prices and at this
time with iPhone sales through the roof
with the iPhone 6 this is actually what
made sense for most buyers and that's
how they captured so much market share
in such a short period of time now that
had the customers and to keep them they
provided great customer service
there was no hidden fees in no overage
costs there are none that crap that
people hated from the other carriers and
perfect for t-mobile all the competitors
were distracted with other ventures AT&T
was busy looking for video customers
buying DirecTV they were also trying to
buy Time Warner but that was held up by
the Empire
last cops and after a Verizon they were
busy fixing their stupid mistakes or as
they would call it offsetting their
investments they went out and bought a
AOL for 4.4 billion dollars yeah well
I'm sure they had the reasons or not but
either way in the end this forced him to
sell off the network ignored afforded
and as for sprint sprint are struggling
with massive debt as they were the weird
option in Italian market it were kind of
trying to match t-mobile with their
super cheap unlimited plans but then
they still have contracts they were
really weird
I think sprint was very busy trying to
figure out with their target and what
even they were doing themselves and this
gave t-mobile the perfect opportunity to
steal all these customers and after
stealing all of these customers t-mobile
has been able to build a great brand
loyalty with their transparency 25% of
t-mobile customers would never switch to
another network no matter the reason
this is only true for 16 percent of AT&T
customers 50% on Verizon customers is 7
percent of Sprint customers t-mobile
definitely took advantage of their
competitors fobbed goals an osteoma grew
and got more money to buy the network's
at AT&T and Verizon were selling off nor
to fund their other ventures this is la
t-mobile to significantly improve their
networks and increase their prices and
still offer a good deal to the public
they have increased their former
unlimited data plan from $100 to 120 to
140 to now $160 which is a total of a 60
percent increase but the thing is this
only affects new users the regional
prices still stand for the people who
bought them at those prices
pretty much all carriers do this they
only increase your fees if the fees
increase for new customers but they also
don't decrease your fees if the fees
decrease for new customers so I guess it
could be a positive or negative but
t-mobile made sure to keep the original
customers very happy and t-mobile really
marker to the unlimited plans as they
made more money on these than comparator
limited plans and capable was really
smart about this their unlimited plans
worked out much more expensive than
their
plans and as a result a lot of people
who spend an extra ten to twenty dollars
a month to get an unlimited plan but
then they're only end up using a couple
of gigabytes per month these people
probably have spent wailers lesson got a
limited plan and would have been flying
and t-mobile gets the pocket of the
extra cash in fact only three percent of
mobile users have an unlimited plans of
t-mobile actually utilize it to its full
potential so the other 97% of people
would actually be better off by buying a
cheaper plan but since t-mobile's plan
are so similar in price people often
think they're getting a good deal by
going with unlimited plan and that's
because it is a good deal but the
problem is that you probably won't take
advantage of it in t-mobile they
capitalize on this people buy it simply
because they think it's a good deal not
because they actually need it and this
has allowed evil to make huge profits
and they have become vastly successful
in fact I just checked on their online
site and I don't even think they offer
limited plans anymore you may be able to
find if you dig deep into their website
but as for the mainstream US market I
don't even think they offered limited
plans anymore it's similar tactics to
what buffets use and it has clearly
worked for tea Bowl you may have
recently heard any news at t-mobile is
trying to acquire sprint and take all of
their customers they are still having
trouble with getting regulars to approve
a deal but they're still trying this has
actually led to ten states suing in an
effort to stop the acquisition and just
last week both companies announced that
baha verdict would come no later than
you liked my 19 so we'll know what
happens in just a couple of weeks but
what does this all mean for t-mobile
well in quarter three or 2018 Verizon
had a one hundred fifty three point nine
million customers AT&T had a 150 point
two million customers t-mobile has
pretty much half of that at seventy
seven point two million customers and
Sprint at fifty three point five million
customers but merging with Sprint get
t-mobile 130 million customers this
would take them from having just half of
what the competitors had to having
almost 90 percent and if they continued
growth with the break they have been
going really Pascal
years.if completely destroyed Verizon
ATT and this type of domination is what
the government doesn't want and that's
why we see so much controversy about it
now what's ironic about all of this is
that just a couple of years ago when he
was in his ditch sprint was considered
to buy them but now it's the exact
opposite way around where Sprint being
in a ditch and table while trying to buy
them now why Springfield can be a video
in itself so make sure to comment that
down below if you like to see that but
anyways that pretty much summarizes
t-mobile efforts with Sprint and through
all of these efforts ledger has been
able to revitalize t-mobile since he
became CEO in 2012 since he has been
appointed the TiVo customer base has
over doubled but he isn't satisfied even
yet he wants to dominate the market
beating a Verizon AT&T through their
sprint acquisition stock prices are
still not as high as they used to be in
the early 2000s when they were over $100
per share but they have been
consistently growing in there around
Sandefur dollars per share right now
which is a significant improvement over
the almost single digit price shares in
2012 and the main reason for all the
success is that john ledger was able to
humanize t-mobile he gave customers what
they wanted for price is cheaper than
even what they are willing to pay this
has built a great brand loyalty enforced
your competitors to following t-mobile's
footsteps Verizon AT&T and Sprint have
all started offer unlimited plans for
cheaper prices and slashed solar
contracts but despite all this t-mobile
is still growing at a rate faster than
ever before
today t-mobile is the third largest
solar network in the United States and
they have truly revolutionized this
market but offering prices never seen
before the whole company just started 25
years ago but now they have grown to
challenge the market leaders they have
had the number of fillers bother new
leadership and a focus on helping and
penetrating customer they're really
gotten successful and this has allowed
them to go from the 2g crap service to
pushing 5g
this is our t-mobile became a behemoth
that they are today but that's all I
have for you guys on t-mobile make sure
you comment down below what company you
would like me to cover next also if you
guys like this video make sure but like
and consider subscribing if you like to
see more videos just like this one but
till then I'm sorry I'll see you guys on
next one